okay a little bit of election news i
have
really good news for people disgusting
extremist ideologue right winger
congressman steve king
from iowa lost i'm sorry from indiana
lost his republican primary last sorry
iowa lost his uh primary yesterday and
is being kicked out of congress
in january this is truly a disgusting
guy
and i am so glad in the midst of just
terrible things going on in our country
to be able to tell you
about something good that has taken
place they voted yesterday
steve king has been ousted by
state senator randy feenstra
king has a history of racially toxic
comments he once
waxed nostalgic about how the term white
supremacists doesn't
didn't used to be offensive he is
irrationally
anti-immigrant he once compared
immigrants to dogs and dirt
in 2013 he said that young documented
immigrants have this is a quote
calves the size of cantaloupes because
they haul
75 pounds of marijuana across the desert
he wanted an electrified fence between
the u.s mexico border
he's complained white people aren't
having enough babies to keep
up with the rapid reproduction of
minorities
he endorsed a white nationalist running
for the mayor of toronto
and he also met with austrian far-right
political party leaders
a party that was founded by a neo-nazi
so he's a horrible guy
he was widely abandoned by the
republican party and that's why
you know this is not glorious news it's
great that king has lost
but the person he lost to randy feenstra
is not great and in fact what's scary is
that feenstra
is running on or ran on steve king is
not an effective ally
for donald trump i can be an effective
ally for donald trump and his big issues
are
to keep the trump tax cuts to protect
christian values not exactly
the best guy scary but hopefully trump
himself will be removed in november and
feenstra won't ever ever get a chance to
serve
with trump even better by the way is
that jd scholten our friend j.d scholten
who unsuccessfully ran to unseat steve
king
back in 2018 is running again so
we don't have to see randy feenstra win
let's support jd scholten great guy
former professional baseball player i
interviewed him back
in 2018 he is running again he is the
democrat running against
randy feenstra let's support him
excellent excellent candidate
we'll have continued coverage of
yesterday's election results
on the david pakman show instagram page
that's david pakman show
all one word on instagram